mon sens monsieur landry rappelle que
vous êtes évidemment une l'ancien pro d2
du québec se retrouveront sans sujet me
reste que au moment de l'exclusion
madame où règne du bloc québécois
vous aviez pris d'une certaine manière
sa défense mais on croit comprendre
parce que monsieur pays nous disait que
déjà madame hourani cheminée est ce que
l'état y est mieux placé que moi pour
eux pour en parler
d'ailleurs soit dit en passant je n'en
mange à payer oui parce que dans des
circonstances extrêmement pénibles a
accepté de jeu c'est parti et c'est la
maladie qui l'a chassé
oui alors bon il faudrait que cela dit
plusieurs fois n'est pas question pour
vous dire les noms peek et poke
questions domaniales et non plus j'ai
fait ma part cela dit quand mariah était
exclu c'est vrai du bloc
ça m'a fait beaucoup de peine mais je
pensais jamais d'avoir une peine
supplémentaire à son sujet et la lay
line aujourd'hui je dois dire que en
démocratie on peut changer de tactique
ce n'est jamais rené lévesque est parti
des libéraux pour fonder le parti
québécois
je n'ai rien comme ça je dois dire aussi
que j'ai pu beaucoup de signes pour
maria mourani disait sur même des amis
et je te dis que je n'annule pas de
façon définitive cette amitié
j'espère que nous nous préparerons et
que nous développerons une sympathie
cela dit je trouve ton changement
d'orientation extrêmement pénible à mes
yeux et aux yeux de nombre
d'indépendants 6 bien sûr mais ton
argumentation est pire que ton geste son
argumentation
je regrette de dire ça est un mépris
pour le peuple québécois d'abord ton
ton adulation de l'achat de taux est
invraisemblable
rené lévesque claude ryan réunis se sont
élevés contre cette infamie la majorité
canadiennes imposé à la nation
québécoise
une constitution contre son opinion
démocratique unique c'est un des gestes
odieux des démocraties occidentales
c'est pas bien si bruxelles changer les
lois européennes contre la volonté de la
france ou de l'allemagne
l'un et l'autre ou les deux fauteuils
qu'en reprenant un peu tu est
admiratrices mme asher maria de gestes
aussi abject je veux dire aux fusils
l'idée des poupées je peux vous du débat
quelques secondes de répondre on voulait
pas de débat mais si elle est modérée
ok alors elle les imériens démocrates
allaient se marier amour haine mais tout
d'abord je tiens à te dire bernard que
pour moi tu n'étais pas mon ami tu es
toujours mon ami et moi c'est d'avoir
mauvaise pas grave mais ma main est
tendue à moi d'autre part je te
lancerait la question je te dirai
comment tu acceptes que le parti
québécois fassent des lois
discriminatoires envers une partie de
notre population et comment tu acceptes
qu'ils utilisent ça pour préparer leurs
prochaines élections et caché leur bilan
économique plus que death last resort
dans l'économie la femme et moi te dire
quand on met la main sur les 60 restants
sur les sujets effectivement c'est que
proposent-ils qui est appuyé fortement
pas un très grand nombre de progressis
québécois parmi lesquels les femmes
musulmanes
j'avais vu cela alors parler de
discrimination là il faut faire
attention aux consonances et qu'on
retrouve de chaque côté pro charte est
un chat à la fois des gens progressiste
à la fois d'efféminé c'est pour ça qu'on
a des sinistres la fois directe
on n'a pas le droit de mépriser un camp
où l'on sait c'est un débat et moi je
remercie le parti québécois d'avoir fait
ce débat qui était temps de faire
parce que dans cette charte fédérale que
tu adule ya une notion père l'est qui
est celle du multiculturalisme le canada
est le seul pays au monde à avoir mis ça
dans sa constitution et les pays qui ont
flirté avec cette notion sont tous en
repentance écouter david cameron premier
ministre britannique
regardez ce que dit angela merkel
regardez ce qui se passe en hollande et
en belgique et ma prévision
je ne suis pas prophète c'est que le
canada va regretter sur la peur de
madame mourani de voir cette division
beaucoup entre francophones annoncé que
le gouvernement a misé sur le
rassemblement des on constate peut-être
que le message envoyé aux communautés
culturelles
certains membres comme l'outil culturel
est repris par un amour n y peut
inquiéter
oui mais certains membres des
communautés que jonah hex dans les
lipides en défenseur de la chatte parce
qu'ils ont compris la perversité du
multiculturalisme la châtre grands
auteurs québécois qui s'appelle neil
bissoondath qui dit que la même critique
rage est une doctrine perverse fournis
allemand ce que je crois aussi
et les premières victimes sont nos
frères et soeurs issues de l'immigration
je ne veux pas que ça soit un dernier
mois ce parce que le temps file ont
terminé madame marois arrive de france -
le président français a dit que pour eux
la laïcité la neutralité c'était le
vivre ensemble
c'était la meilleure façon d'exprimer
l'égalité de tous devant la religion
oui tout à fait et en même temps que ces
bons plats france-presse moments plus
calmes et ses matériaux et en même temps
en même temps que monsieur hollande dit
ça on a un rapport qui est remis à son
premier ministre français qui dit que
c'est un échec
moi j'ai vécu en france l'intégration en
france est un échec que l'on veut une un
état laïc je pense qu'on est tous passés
par là dessus on est tous d'accord mais
à une façon de faire la laïcité est ce
que le québec pourrait développer son
échec des nullards écoute
sarkozy ancien président de la
république avait trois grands parents
sur quatre n'était pas né en france il
s'est tellement intégrée qui était plus
français que bien des français savaient
millions d'africains et de maghrébins
qui vivent dans des ghettos en france
110 stations et je ne fais pas dans une
jambe et au nom même dans un siècle
c'est je peux vous le dire souvent ce
genre de danse appelée ben zur
républicaine qui à la terre qui est en
chine et celle supérieure d'études
récentes études le démontrent c'est un
échec mais l'angleterre
le mot de la fin peut-être avec vous
bernard landry est est ce que ce
revirement là aura des conséquences
imprévues il peine à voir les deux
techniques est parce que l'attak de
maria et je m'excuse pas et je n'attaque
rien je donne opinion non alors ce que
tu as dit on va terminer le peuple
québécois et de la révision de la
constitution de l'indépendance c'est du
mépris jeu tu penses tu sais que je vais
mal parlé de mon sens le mépriser le
québécois s'est pas forcément être
souverainiste ou fédéraliste québécois
québécois politiquement ce soir j'ai dit
que j'avais beaucoup d'hommes et de
femmes issues de l'immigration qui a pu
la merde j'ai jamais insulté mon peuple
alors selon moi merci la quadrilla ce
que tu as dis là c'est méprisant merci
merci lundi alors on va merci beaucoup à
tous les deux chèques sur un débat très
émouvant je sens qu'elle avait des fêtes
ça va être émouvant là dans toutes les
femmes toutes les faibles merci à tous
les deux
pas prévu le débat n'était pas prévu
merci merci rené lévesque colette
entendent aussi sec est un grand
démocrate